what's up guys welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment I'm your host Walter
Brennan siak and today we are talking
about a great animated movie in my
opinion it's Green Lantern first flight
the 2009 DC animated movie I'm gonna get
some great people to talk about today
hey Heather you had a really cool
Facebook video this past week about
comics in the classroom what's going on
yeah yeah you know if you haven't
checked it out it's on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
show sorry guys
it's getting a lot of good reception
yeah good I'm glad you know it's an
interesting topic yeah touch you mr.
Brian Porter how's it going man
good oh really collection though sorry
got the orange ring on you guys you guys
get it so I find a way what's up me
what's up hey
okay talk about Green Lantern I'm green
with excitement know what it doesn't
exactly work but let's jump into it okay
so a Green Lantern first play like I
said 2009 dcmn movie one of the first
ones cuz the first the first one in the
line of the DC animated original movies
was Superman doomsday which we've talked
about in 2007 so this is one of the
earlier ones
let's go into posit first what do we
like about green lanten first flight
Heather
um well I think overall it's just a
solid movie like the pacing I think is
really good you get a good mix of like
the action but the plot isn't hard to
follow so I think that the good pacing
really helps keep you like engrossed the
whole time I also think some of the art
is really good I was saying before I
like some of the opening shots we get of
some of the settings as we're introduced
to them like the first time we're
introduced to OA and we get that nice
like view of the whole planet yeah would
you like about this one um I actually
really liked how much story we got out
of this it didn't seem too much it
didn't seem too little I know there's a
lot of people who went to go see
when it was premiered at comic-con that
were upset a little bit with the origin
story and a little bit upset that it was
less how but I liked how much Sinestro
was in it
I thought it was a really good storyline
we got to see his like progress from a
Green Lantern into being turned into
yellow lantern like I I loved the story
of it actually and I thought the plot
was great yeah I thought it was a good
introduction to all these characters I
mean the Green Lantern universe is a
ton of characters and it's hard
even as a fan who was reading and been
reading for years hard to remember all
these Carrie oh yeah but it's a good
introduction a lot of most of them like
all the big ones got screen time you got
a little bit of a feel for every single
one of them you know the guardians and
you know ganthet and how he's the only
one who makes sense and not a dick so
you know it's just you got a you got a
good feel for everybody except for Carol
Ferris really but other than that you
got a really good feel for everybody and
I think it was a solid introduction all
these characters the fact that it didn't
go anywhere after this movie kind of
sucks but you know we didn't have any
follow-ups to this movie but right and
this wasn't really based on anything you
know specific I mean it's based on the
the in general of Sinestro turning to
you know this in a film or what else
don't know yeah house origin a little
bit I mean it shows they're like a buddy
cop film sort of yeah so it doesn't yeah
I sort of build on anything that's big
in the comics except for just real
general storylines but I still think was
a sob movie yeah my my in general
thoughts about this I am glad that we
got to see a little bit of Adam sir
because he is a really good character
and we saw some stuff in comics that
he's a really great Red Lantern Green
Lantern he's kind of red pinkish but
he's a green like me after day at the
beach so it was cool seeing that and
then we got that little flashback when
Boudicca touches rings with how we see
like so what led to him giving up the
Lantern ring and dying and everything so
that was really cool I love Michael
Madsen his Kilowog I don't care if I
said I think it's perfect
like I don't why all I wanted I hear him
in it's just I expect Kilowog to cut off
someone's ear and really can you hear me
like that's all anything he's like
perfect voice haha no no Michael Clarke
Duncan was the perfect Kilowog in Green
Lantern yeah he was perfect regardless
regardless he was perfect I want a
Kilowog asthma with Michael Clarke
Duncan is fantastic right Michael Madsen
it's just well it was just I didn't
think it was like in the later in the
later movies when Nathan Fillion going
back in hearing Christopher Meloni again
was a little bit like yeah we can see
that point yeah I did like the guy who
voiced us an asteroid from legends yeah
yeah he was very sour yeah there you go
I thought he was pretty sour Sinestro
yeah I think you found it a little bit
of a menace yeah it still was very kind
of upright you know right part yeah you
can tell you smart yeah I thought they
yeah that voice casting was pretty good
the animation style let's talk about
that really quick so I think it was
pretty solid but there was a few times
where it kind of everyone seems sort of
off the model like the heads got really
small a couple times in the bodies sort
of got really wide and didn't stay
consistent throughout the entire thing
but in general I did like the animation
style how everything moved and the
action scenes I thought were I mean
really well what do you think the only
thing that killed me with some of the
CGI like one sinestro's core like to the
lander before that he makes the battery
yeah it makes some really exactly it
looked totally out of place sometimes
that's what killed me okay times the CGI
batteries don't like it going
CGI
I did love what there's a couple other
CG moments in here at the beginning I
think when house test flight simulator
whatever I thought that better than just
inconsistent overall when it was good it
was good and then there were other times
that it was it was a little hokey the
only thing I was like really kind of
weird on it was it was just weird
looking but it wasn't they shrunk down
Sinestro's head yeah like he usually has
like that big forehead I think he looks
fine though they changed up a couple
character character medicine Kilowog for
the most part looks the same yeah chip I
like character tomar Raymond say right
just about the same yeah the character
Morrow's changed a little bit but for
the most part I think they were on track
with how they look in the comics and in
other movies that we've seen or TV shows
or whatever let's go into negatives
really quick so talking about what we
like about this one so I think we all
agree this is not the best DCM in movie
or II didn't like what's in the top ten
so what did we not like about it I over
all mostly like to this movie but I can
understand how I mean I know I know
people had problems with Hal Jordan it's
like origin story only being the first
like three four it's not really sure
it's really sure I'm fine with that
though everyone just move the story
along like we all know many origin story
older if you don't know though right
like you get it right I think maybe the
only problem I could have with how short
it is is that he sort of just accepts
being a Green Lantern so fast yeah he's
like we're in space and I'm doing
like we don't see any of the like
progress I guess yeah yeah but like all
of a sudden he's got he knows how to fly
and brings a thing in then he comes in
he's got the Bluetooth
and I'm just like how did you figure out
just any sort of like lead up to that so
I think that would be my one problem but
other other than that I liked it being
short and sweet because we can move on
to the rest of the story sure I also
don't really see this much as a Hal
Jordan story maybe because of that it's
more of a Sinestro move right rather
than a first light yeah it's more about
like the split story because having
Sinestro and their parallels and then
separating everything but we we get to I
mean if we see a villain or an antihero
at all we usually don't get as much of
their story if we're seeing the hero
story we got to see Sinestro side of
basically everything right right that's
what I thought yeah I was like for being
a Green Lantern movie I'm much more
intrigued by Sinestro his plotline than
males yeah there wasn't you know the
thing that is in humanizes how is like
his sort of connection to earth and his
connection to Carroll and his nephews
and his brothers and stuff or dad yeah
but it's a big thing and we don't get
any of that right here so I think that
maybe that's why he connected more to
Sinestro yeah yeah for anything that
sort of took out two is not the best
yeah like like I said with his like all
of a sudden being able to just do it and
he's totally correct Oh butch alien
sweet what up but uh one of my things
that I kind of bugged me a little bit
was when Sinestro killed
Chandra row voiced by Kurtwood Smith
which is awesome when he just straight
up right through and it's like Green
Lantern's can't kill well in economics
they can well they I think the key well
they can't help but like up and for a
long time wasn't it sinister of course
war or black blackest night when they
took off Sinestro Corps war yeah it took
off the no killing and everybody's like
what the hell
authorised for lethal force yeah and
that was like a big deal it was a big
part of that comic right and semester
just kills them and everybody's like
that I kind of like that scene I kind of
don't where he just brings him back to
life was her belt Bela Rose yeah that
was a little scary some drug use there
who's that for scenario take like
yeah so I wanted to talk really quick
about the ending here so how basically
absorbs the the green element in this
and he turns in like Super Saiyan Green
Lantern no which is super cool I mean
he's basically I on on this yeah
iron in the comics is the like the
physical embodiment of the the green
element basically and he goes into
different people at different points and
kyle rayner is is iron for a long time
the comics was years ago but so it's
basically that same concept where he
absorbs all the power and he gets to
fight Sinestro and I love that action
soon like a about that fight was me yeah
yeah so that was really fun I even like
the Far Away when we see them like
fireworks with the right well I don't
know I thought it was really satisfying
to when they even just stopped using the
constructs and we're like alright I just
really yeah yeah yeah it played really
well on screen I think just because the
you know the green versus the yellow
looked really cool and just yeah the
fight in general like the you know the
big fists and everything they were
coming the constructs yeah like we're
talking about it looks really good so
yeah one thing I really liked about the
like towards the end was the like how
all the Rings came down and yeah that
was very deep in like you see that in
the comics like you see like a on a
ring zoom by and people are like you're
in space it just has a lot of weight in
this but even more if you read the
comics we don't see that in the know
like that same amount and then we just
how many of them just fell at 1 1 times
oh no there's that's ton of Green
Lantern's dead yeah stroke killed a lot
of people yeah yeah he's definitely dead
oh I want to mention really quick those
uh those aliens on card oh oh
the line is like the only super cool
yeah yeah just a little tidbit I thought
it was really cool so where would this
rank in terms of the landscape of dcmn
movies I mean there's been I think 30
something at this point where would this
rank for you guys is it in the middle is
it towards the bottom yeah probably
towards the top of the middle like near
to the top 10 right I'd have to put my
list together but like I think it's like
near top 10 but not right in the top 10
right I would put it near the middle as
well because like you said it's one of
the first ones so you can still see some
of the growing pains I guess you could
say like you to little details like the
music and animation style you know like
those things that could take it up to
the next level if it would have been
made like in the more of the heyday of
yeah yeah towards the middle
I wouldn't I feel like there's been
worse ones but like there's been some
really really good ones we've gotten
recently so yeah it doesn't really quite
measure up to those I agree like years
ago it would've by wow we've got so much
better what the hell right I mean cuz
like I said this wasn't really based on
anything specific from the comics we're
like a lot of the really good dcmn
movies are based off of stuff from the
comics you know like you know Dark
Knight Returns is incredible right I
mean you're one I really like I thought
that was a really good anime movie even
super Ian doomsday I thought you know
while it didn't follow the story of the
death and return of Superman still had
the feel of it and everything so yeah
with this it was cool I wanted to see
more we didn't get to see more but one
thing we got from that was you know
Emerald might Emerald Knights which I
don't think is as good I mean it's okay
but I don't think it's as good as this
yeah I would love to see the Geoff Johns
adapted story is getting so between like
Gladys Knight Sinestro Corps war rebirth
even like secret origin would be great
to see animated
like it would be amazing to see that
stuff in animated form and I know they
did the animated series which is only
lasted one season it got kind of sirs
and ceremoniously cancelled but I would
love to see anime and movies because I
think they're built for movies oh
absolutely that's how geoff johns kind
of writes right sort of like this
cinematic type style something like a
two or three part black is hai series
with all that so much money right just
take it out of the continuities a whole
thing that they've got going out city
has animation with and all the new to
figure out of there's a separate entity
like just owe you so much food series
you buy the out of it they're a
special editions no problem absolutely I
mean it just seems because blackest
night was so like basically mainstream
popular with all a different colored
lanterns right I mean obviously we have
all our hearings right here it sort of
shocked me that they didn't adapt it
yeah it's kind of weird to me and
there's other great stories I've been
talking about the geoff johns and you
could go back and tell i mean there's a
ton of great stuff so i don't know why i
haven't done it is it maybe because the
live-action seems like they just want to
stay with the top three but mainly
batman i mean most of the but like
Batman is usually in most of them I
think they just they know what they what
cells and where but they don't really
want to deviate and then with the DL
like well the merge yeah when blackest
night was out anyway I mean all these
things are all icon bookstores
everywhere and stuff all the different
shirts that came out like a nose up make
it happen
yeah make it happen Jeff is in charge of
DC Entertainment now yeah Jeff man let's
secretly rock that we want to buy it
what do you bring back I don't know if
he has any influence on the animated
side of things but I don't know like
give him a little nudge nudge like snake
happy once you read this
who's Tim again he was he was a big
driving force behind animated series
which did have the different colored
lanterns but like some cool animated
movies could come out of this
and the different story arcs and
live-action I think would be really cool
I still don't know what's gonna happen
with live-action the Green Lantern I
don't know who's gonna be the Green
Lantern was gonna be Jon Stewart if it's
gonna be held right well Jeff is Jeff is
the Green Lantern guy is the see that's
the thing though like when he was
executive producer on gl and it was just
like yeah but he why didn't he talk so
bad if Geoff Johns was attached I don't
think he had as much influence over it
though I think he just was sort of on
there by name and they kind of consulted
him for a few things executive producer
I mean that could mean a lot anything
could be nothing
right could be just a name on a movie so
you don't know but I but there's so much
like history and great stories from his
run of Green Lantern well you could you
could tell 10 movies 10 live a great
just give us some more Green Lantern cuz
we want to see it good I would I would
kill to see Atrocitus and Sam Walker
like that one scene when atrocities on
his knees and he starts crying about his
dead family like that is such a powerful
scene right a part in the book and to
see that I'm even just an amazing yeah I
was telling you guys before we start
record about the sodam yat fight with
the superboy-prime yeah Sinestro Corps
war that fight in the comics is if you
put that on animation I think it would
ever look great in live-action but I
think that's built for an animation
right I mean let us know in the comments
guys like what do you think went the
best animated Green Lane Drive movie do
you guys want to see his review or do a
top 10 episodes of the Green Lantern
animated series I mean that wouldn't
take too much talk about that cuz I do I
do like that show I haven't seen all the
episodes but from what I saw I did like
it so it'd be cool to check that out so
let us know let's go ahead and pick a
week here so I did bring one of the
Geoff Johns books it is secret origin so
it's kind of we get a little bit of that
origin here but this is so much more
fleshed out this should have been the
anime movie it should have been my
dreams they could origin the animated
movie because there's so much great
stuff in here with how like we're
talking about with his brothers and his
father and his nephews and him being
tethered to earth by Carol Ferris and
all that stuff all the background that
makes him a great character is in this
and you get to see stuff with Jon
Stewart
he was in the military they're both in
the military at the same time a
different thinking how I was in the Air
Force I can't remember where yeah Jon
Stewart was a Marine and seeing them
interact was really cool yeah their
military backgrounds matched up pretty
well so yeah go check out real Antron
secret origin it's a great book and a
great introduction I think to the Jeff
Jones run of Green Lantern and just
Green Lantern general it's really fun
ok social media for everybody Heather
what's going on man yeah you can find me
on Twitter at Heather ruse or on
Instagram at a truce yeah tell some more
stories about your classroom yeah yeah I
tend to get more into that on Twitter
and Instagram so if you are interested
in that from the facebook video check
those out
check them out where can we find you
Facebook Twitter thank you
and snapchat post pictures behind the
scenes videos from Six Flags that you
didn't get to see in the video of us on
rides and stuff so all that sorts of
stuff that doesn't always make it onto
the episode will be on my snapchat jacob
supporter take a do it huh check it
hey booty face book on slash awesome
board all right Porter face book they go
together like pamper and Jillian yeah
you can find me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and talking about
whatever talking about you know all
these DC anime and movies any kind of
superhero movie or whatever you want to
talk to me about go ahead and talk me
about it or the top 5 show I do a lot of
people ask me what actor I'm doing next
just go ahead and talk to me give me
suggestions I'm always open to that
stuff ok so next week that's the return
of our vs. series very excited about
that it's gonna be on of vs. me and it's
gonna be fun
they are characters that we will reveal
next week a little surprise for you guys
but we're finally gonna switch over to
Marvel I'll say that because we've been
doing DC for like six months yeah so
we're switching over to Marvel finally
yeah so we're gonna have fun with that
okay so what was what's the Green
Lantern oath you
I do last night no evil shall escape my
sight let those who worship evils might
beware my power